Elon Musk spoon fed you his
cherry-picked information which you must
have suspected promotes a slanted
viewpoint or at the very least generates
another right-wing conspiracy theory
this isn't just a matter of what data
was given to these so-called journalists
before us now my name is Matt taibi I'm
not a so-called journalist I've won the
national magazine award the I have stone
award for independent journalism and
I've written 10 books including four New
York Times bestsellers before Matt taibi
was sparring with Democratic members of
Congress on Capitol Hill earlier this
year over the Twitter files he was a
darling of the progressive left
appearing regularly on shows like
democracy Now Bill Moyers and Rachel
Maddow Matt taibi his new article for
Rolling Stone magazine why isn't Wall
Street in jail the Bush Administration
these are people some of the people
these they're some of the greatest Liars
in the history of politics and even they
couldn't come up with a connection
between Al-Qaeda and and Saddam Hussein
though he was always a fierce crit of
the democratic establishment the rise of
Donald Trump suddenly meant that anyone
nominally left of center even
Progressive journalists like taibi were
expected to support Hillary Clinton
unconditionally so when he attacked her
as a sellout argued that the russiagate
narrative was mostly [__] and
equated the manipulative tactics of both
right and left media personalities he
found himself cold-shouldered by
progressives and Democrats started
treating him like a puppet for the right
do you think it's a legitimate objective
of the FBI to stop foreign interference
in our elections I think it's the
legitimate objective to stop actual
foreign interference okay
I mean I don't know what the difference
is but that's fine in 2020 taibi started
publishing his work on substack and
quickly became one of the platform's
most popular writers earning far more
Revenue than he ever did at Rolling
Stone
yourself posted on your your
um I guess it's kind of like a web page
and don't quite understand what substack
is but it became even more of a parai by
publishing exhaustive reports that
documented extensive governmental
interference seeking to control what was
said on Twitter about covid-19 and
efforts by Russia to influence U.S
elections Congressional Democrats
pilloried him as a fake journalist a
Putin apologist and a stooge for Elon
Musk it's quite obvious that you've
profited from the Twitter files it's
probably a wash honestly didn't you
consider Mr must to be the direct source
of all this no now you're you're trying
to get me to say that he is the source I
I I well
he's a journalist and he can't because
either musk is the source and he can't
talk about it or musk is not the source
and if musk is not the source then he
can discuss no one has yielded the
gentle lady's out of order but he said
is he's not going to reveal his source
and the fact that Democrats are
pressuring
reason caught up with taibi at Freedom
Fest in annual Gathering help this year
in Memphis to talk about the new
challenges to free speech white Legacy
Media is dying and how identity politics
are poisoning political discourse
Matt taibi thanks for talking to reason
so great to talk to you again nick uh so
let's talk about the Twitter files first
when you went into the you know kind of
sealed room and things like that what
were you expecting to find
not much
um
I went into the Twitter files with a
very old school
um Antiquated kind of First Amendment
conception of what we might find or you
know or what questions we might answer
we discussed with Twitter's management
the idea of focusing on the suppression
of the hunter Biden story mainly because
um Mark Zuckerberg had given an
interview
uh and had testified before Congress in
which he suggested that the FBI had
tipped him off about that story so I
thought
if there were those kinds of
communications with Twitter this might
be where we found them uh and I wanted
to know what those Communications look
like
uh
as we discovered there we we didn't find
them in that case but we found an
enormous quantity of quantity of them
elsewhere and it turned into a much more
complicated story than I anticipated
does it I mean like does the Twitter
files really is it the final nail in the
coffin of the idea that there is a clean
distinction between the government and
the media you know because that kind of
informed for a long time you know if you
if you think back to like the Pentagon
papers or something it's like well the
New York Times is separate from the
government and it's not communicating in
the way that it seemed like you know in
the Twitter files it's like there are
tons of people at Twitter saying hey FBI
or whatever take a look at this and then
various government actors are saying hey
you really need to look at this and do
something about it
I I would say that it puts the final
nail on the coffin of that narrative I
actually feel guilty for being naive
about that
um again I grew up in the media my
father was you know in television and I
was around newsrooms most of my
childhood the idea that the FBI might
call up and say Hey you might want to
think about not doing this story
that would be crazy I can't I I couldn't
have even imagined an editor or a news
director who would have even taken that
call uh you know in that way and we
found in the Twitter files all kinds of
things that suggested that this
relationship was not only uh tolerated
but that it was ongoing regular and
collusive in a way that was kind of
shocking to me I think what's a specific
example of that a great example of this
was the um the Aspen Institute tabletop
exercise which was technically not set
up by the government
it was set up by the Aspen Institute
which is funded by the government in
collaboration with some
um academic institutions that had been
briefed by the FEC and some government
agencies but they all got together
before the release of the hunter Biden
story they were briefed by current and
former government officials who talked
about the possibility that a hack and
leak story involving Hunter Biden and
barisma might come out and they kind of
war game the possibility of what to do
about that story and then a month later
that story happens now for me
if I had been in that room
and that story actually happened a month
later I would feel obligated to do a
story about that tabletop exercise I
would say hey what a weird coincidence
that this thing happened but these
people had you know an off the Record
arrangement with everybody they were in
the room with and they
um they kept to it they kept quiet and
you know that's a completely new level
of cooperation and coordination that you
know I would never have imagined and I
mean what did I guess did it work or did
it not to suppress the story because
that I mean this is a slightly different
question like was it a Streisand effect
where you know the New York Post
publishes something about Hunter Biden a
couple weeks before the election and
people are like yeah you know it's the
New York Post but then I remember like
going to Twitter when I heard about it
and then it was like you can't link to
it from Twitter or anything and that was
really chilling like that was the first
time I felt I was in like an Orwell
novel or something where it's like what
do you mean like you can't
you can't link to it or discuss it on
Twitter but
you know I mean do you think did it work
first and then let's talk about like why
they thought it might or might not have
I'm not sure I mean I I think that would
be worth studying yeah it would be
interesting to do some surveys about
that and find out
um what the actual impact of that was uh
I think overall in the long run
certainly that story got more attention
um than it would have absent this
however we're also learning uh you know
I think there's more about that story
that's going to come out fairly soon
my understanding is that there are some
depositions that are on underway that
there are things that are happening in
Washington where some of those
committees uh you know that are
oversight committees are still looking
at that issue and the stuff that was on
the laptop because we didn't know a
whole lot when that first story came out
all we knew was that they found the
laptop they didn't know a whole lot
about whether any of those emails were
meaningful
um all we knew was that we had some some
racy looking pictures it was
embarrassing
um but you know it's going to take some
hardcore investigation to to find out
whether there's anything behind that and
that process in many cases takes years
I would just say they probably were
effective installing that you know
um also there's the alternate
um
story where they
told people in mainstream media that
this was Russian disinformation and I
think that was effective with Biden
voters like that story had an effect in
getting people to ignore the idea that
this was anything worth paying attention
to you I mean you obviously kind of
started your career in Russia you know
in in the post-soviet world was this
kind of collusion between the government
and news was that taken for granted
there I mean is this are we looking like
you know Russia and I don't know you
know in the late 90s or something yeah
like 1999 2000 I think that was when you
first started to see directly
um
you know the news stations resembling
basically press releases for the Kremlin
in the in the mid to late Yeltsin years
the Press was sort of stratified and
fractured each of the different news
companies was was basically backed by a
different mob and or Mafia interest
um and they all had their own ties to
yelts and but basically you were looking
at the point of view or this or that
oligarch when you watch the news when
Putin came to power one of the first
things he did is he really Consolidated
the media landscape he cracked down on
companies like enteve which is one of
the last Independence stations and he
got it so that there was basically no
dissent in Russian media and it's
beginning to feel a little bit like that
although it's it's not because like if
you you know if if you descend from you
know Biden you're going to start eating
polonium without knowing it right so
right can you discuss us the like what
are the steps that are happening you
know and it's not like against the
media's interest or or against media
actors they're like bringing it on and
Twitter and Facebook was filled with
people who had been in an Administration
then moved there to do like you know
Communications or strategy and it goes
back and forth like how are we getting
to a place where Twitter which you know
its first big Glory was in helping to uh
kind of platform the Arab Spring and
like it was good it was great because it
was anti-government and it was
anti-censorship and now it's you know
[__] like doing the the it's you know
the towel boy for a particular Vision I
don't want to say the Deep state but
like of a Centrist kind of mainstream
ideological politics yeah I think I
think that's right
um there's obviously a huge difference
yeah between what happened in Russia I
mean I I knew people like Anna
polacowska who you know got murdered
under of the Putin regime there were a
couple of others I knew who had had some
pretty unfortunate Fates nobody's
getting shot in their doorway right you
know in the United States but that's
actually one of the more depressing
Parts about our story is that this is
all voluntary what's going on
um the overall The overarching Narrative
that we
um
collectively working on the Twitter
files decided was happening was that
there was a huge
infrastructure that had been built up
for counter proliferation
counter-terrorism within the government
it was aimed at the messaging apparatus
of groups like Isis
to prevent uh you know this successful
recruitment of white kids and Suburban
England and California well when you
know that threat dissipated they moved
over to populism in the United States
and because as you say
Twitter which had been this incredible
Force for you know Anarchy and the you
know the
um irrepressible political urges of the
population and the Arab Spring it kind
of came out again with Trump I mean
Trump bypassed the the ordinary media in
2016 and his
um amazing Insight was that I can just
use my own Twitter account and I'll have
much more reach than all of these
different stations combined and I think
that freaked out a lot of people in
power and and what we saw in the Twitter
files essentially was a long
um period of rollback which they
achieved through various different means
did they do that and I realized you you
may not be in a position to uh know but
like did they do that against the wishes
of people like Jack Dorsey and the top
kind of creators of Twitter you know
because there's one one narrative which
is that what's going wrong and kind of
social media companies it's not the
people at the top or who started it but
it's like mid-level managers who are all
like you know what we are good liberal
slash progressives and you know we're
really scared of like America and so we
are going to censor people and you know
Dorsey and these other guys are kind of
walking around the c-suite like Howard
Hughes they don't and they they're like
oh you know we don't have any power I
mean who was who made these kind of
operative decisions
it's funny
um before the first Twitter files I had
one fairly senior Twitter executive joke
to me that Jack Dorsey was more like the
company's spirit animal than its CEO
yeah um I had talked to Jack before I I
like him I think he's uh at heart got a
lot of sympathy for uh Free Speech
principles I think they were important
to him yeah
um but if you look at the Twitter files
you see that he's not in the loop of a
lot of these key decisions the things
that happened
particularly around that one incident
involving the hunter Biden story he was
definitely not involved in that one of
the weird ways that I know about that is
because I have found believe it or not
uh on my first day looking at the
Twitter files that Jack Dorsey had
forwarded to Vijaya God the woman who's
basically running things one of my
articles complaining about
um you know the
censorship of that article
he was definitely a free speech Advocate
but he was not
um he he really wasn't at the helm when
they came to the decision to take Trump
off the platform
um you know I think he was dragged
Kicking and Screaming to that decision
and uh most of the company was was
against him at that point yeah
um with the uh kind of Russia gate or
you know the russiagate narrative is
that the Russians wanted and correct me
or you know massage this into what you
believe you know is that Russia was
proactive they wanted Trump to win and
they were going to end more than that it
was also that the Trump campaign was
actively working with them and that
seemed is that like the hinge point of
like we're gonna look back and there's
like media before
2016 and after and how did how did the
Russia gate story spin out because I
mean there have been tons of
congressional investigations and others
and like they've really come up with
nothing in terms of collusion right so
why is it you know why did it get
started and then why is it persisting
after like you know just we got nothing
except you know wish a dream a desire
that it's true
well the Russian gate story oddly enough
became
um sort of involuntarily uh very
important in my life personally I think
it's really the reason I ended up
leaving mainstream media where I was
very happy I had a uh you had the job
everybody wanted right yeah I mean yeah
I mean who doesn't want to be the
campaign reporter for Rolling Stone
magazine right it's like the coolest
thing in the world that's one of the
iconic gigs you can have
um but when the uh the rush kit story
happened as you mentioned there were
really two different story lines one was
that Russia had interfered somehow and
they had a couple of different
inflection points that they were looking
at there was the hack
um dunno was working with Wikileaks and
you know some other things but the more
important narrative that I thought
um they were pushing was this idea of
collusion and I never saw anything that
indicated anything like heart proof for
that and
um I at first all I said I wrote a
couple of various gentle columns in the
beginning saying this looks a little bit
like the wmd mistake where we have an
awful lot of anonymous
State officials who are telling us
things that we can't reproduce in the
laboratory independently there's no way
to check this story right but everybody
was going for it and I think you know
it's as simple as people thought
everything was permitted in pursuit of
getting rid of Donald Trump I mean there
was a very influential article in the
New York Times in August of 2016 called
uh Trump is testing the Norms of
objectivity in journalism and uh the
columnist Jim Rutenberg argued
we can't just be true anymore we have to
be true to history's judgment and so and
that's also great where Trump was uh you
know it's just so weird like everybody's
like he is destroying Norms therefore we
are going to throw over our Norms Pro
preemptively to get rid of him and it's
like okay yeah whatever I mean it like
it worked great in Iraq right preemptive
War preemptive war against Trump has
worked out pretty well
it's like they're incapable of learning
anything you know from any of these
mistakes and and with the Russian gate
thing it was like it was happening in
slow motion the entire time I mean they
kept stepping in it one story after
another and instead of walking it back
or
um you know re-examining the evidence uh
they would double down they would say
what I realize this is you know asking
us psychologize but like why was why
were mainstream people and it's you know
mostly it's kind of like liberal
Centrist liberals uh Legacy Media types
but also you know I don't know like
people in newer Publications like they
wanted that to be true and it was like
I'm old enough to remember reruns of I
Dream of Jeannie or like Three's Company
where it's like every week Mr Roper is
finally going to catch Jack Tripper in a
homosexual tryst and that would never
happen yeah and like you know Dr Bellas
is you know this time he's got Tony down
to rights and it's like it never
happened and you would think
15 times in you'd be like yeah maybe I
you know let's write a different plot
right right exactly you still enjoy the
show though yeah that's true that's true
right yeah and and
um you know and they're still doing it
right they are still doing it uh if you
go back and look you could see why it
was compelling television you can see
why MSNBC shot to the top of the ratings
for the first time in 20 years uh this
looked like you know the end of the
world this was the millerite prediction
you know of you know the world was going
to come to the to an end and it was
going to happen on live TV and you
better not turn it off because you know
it might happen while over on the air
right they would even do if you watch
the the tosses between one show to
another
um they would sort of guide you from one
show to the next and warn you that you
better not turn the dial because between
Lawrence O'Donnell and Rachel it might
happen you know and
um this was very compelling TV I yeah I
understand why they did it but the
problem was you know you were setting
yourself up you were writing checks that
you were going to have to cash at some
point and you know that's a very
dangerous place to be I mean one of the
things I always liked about journalism
is that when you're done with the story
it's done you're you know you go to
sleep and you don't have to think about
it anymore this thing was like the sort
of Damocles like hanging over the whole
business and I I don't understand what
people were thinking I know a lot of the
Old Timers were were very worried about
it but but they're kind of all gone
they're all gone exactly yeah so
um you know with the is
you know does what's interesting is that
Russia gate was primarily among liberals
who you know and none of this I guess is
true but like during the Cold War it was
like well the conservatives were The
Real Americans and they understood that
the Soviet Union and and you know by
extension the Russian people were evil
and you can't really do business with
evil and the Liberals were more like no
you know we have to work peacefully and
now it's weird because it's liberals who
are like Russia Russia Russia like
they're evil and now we have
conservatives who are like you know
Putin you know get Putin a chance or
something like you know how do you
explain like these weird flips it's like
you know what every million years or
something the the North and South Pole
flip and then you but then it feels like
okay it's always been this way like
where is that coming from
well I originally thought it was because
I had gone crazy like that something was
wrong with me personally I think that
was a common experience of a lot of
people like it must be me like this this
must all make sense somewhere
um outside of my understanding but if
you look back I can't remember which one
of them said it I feel like it's either
Jim Clapper or Ted Lou but there was a
prominent politician it said something
like the Russian is genetically
predisposed to deceive or something like
that like this was a comment a
politician made and it flew all over
social media and it wasn't condemned it
was like you know sort of upheld
um and again as you say back in the
Soviet days one of the principal liberal
um ideas was that you know the the
Russian person is not guilty right there
was the sting song You Know Russian
mothers love their children too right
exactly that was that was staying and
you know Richard Pryor said you know hey
if you don't have that hat on I don't
know I don't know the Russians don't
have the Hat on I don't know who the
[__] he is yeah like they're just people
just like us
um that all went out the window when
this started and why I have no idea
um you let's talk a little bit about
leaving Rolling Stone uh when when did
you leave exactly
uh I guess I left in 2019 right and you
you went to substack immediately you
were one of the original people which
also was fascinating when subsex started
and then when it came out they were
paying some people then there was like
again from kind of Legacy Media or like
Cub reporters who were pissed they
weren't getting 200 Grand advances we're
like that's wrong like why should people
be paid to do independent journalism
right it was bizarre but what led to the
rupture with rolling stone because like
you were saying I mean you know that
what a great position to be in
um you know it's a it's a coveted slot
Rolling Stone it's weird because yeah
when it started in 67 but it quickly
became like mainstream publication
mainstream journalism what led to the
rupture there
yeah first of all I love Rolling Stone I
I'll always have a soft spot in my heart
for it I think it had
um a couple of really long hey days
where it did unbelievable work it was
great as music journalism for a long
time it was it was Innovative in
bringing it
um Hunter Thompson's style of writing to
political journalism and I think you
know that's become iconic now right they
brought pgr work in uh then you know
when I was there in the early 2000s and
mid-2000s the owner John wenner was
absolutely against a lot of the stuff
that I wrote Because I was reporting on
financial corruption that didn't look
good for the Democratic party
um sometimes but he was cool with it
he's you know that was a rare thing like
in journalism it's not often when your
boss says I hate this but go for it you
know
um that's what makes a magazine great
and
but that started to change I think after
Trump everybody's tolerance for
um you know sort of exploring different
points of view kind of dried up and I
didn't leave because I was pressured or
pushed out the door it was really more
that I had a sense that there was
something more lucrative and more
rewarding out there on the independent
front
um so are you making more money on
substack than you were for Rolling Stone
a lot more really can you say how much
more like I I don't want to say make us
all feel bad not just me but the camera
guys for let's just say that I'm making
many times over more than I was making
at Rolling Stone what do you what
accounts for that I mean part of it is
sub stack I mean the code they kind of
cracked was allowing people to be able
to easily monetize an audience right but
you know what I mean how how do you
account for like the idea so basically
what you showed and you know I think
Mata glasius leaving Vox has done this
um I think Glenn Greenwald it's
interesting since he started the
intercept and then was like God I hate
this place and the feelings were mutual
but like when you get to a place where a
writer like you somehow if you're making
you know I don't know five times what
you were making it Rolling Stone you
were carrying a ton of people at Rolling
Stone like what what's the appeal do you
think like for you Unbound
well there was a couple of things one
um any writer who's ever worked for
editors and I've benefited massively
from the editors I had like you know
will Dana Eric Bates right I had great
editors at Rolling Stone and
um you know I would never say that
they're bad for a writer but there is
something to be said for when you turn
um and you want to write what you want
to write about uh and there's nobody to
say no that feels pretty good and
sometimes that comes out in the writing
too by the way do you are you edited now
or is it like I mean or just copy
editing or something yeah we do copy
editing sometimes we do fact checking it
depends on what kind of piece it is
because I mean it's fast I I totally and
I'm 10 years older I think than you or
roughly so I get that but it's also as
an editor I like yeah you know my best
work was done when I had to explain
myself to a pre-reader on some level
right right there is some of that you
know I mean like on on one level yes I
would love to be writing working with an
editor
but a it's an expense B
there's a speed element now to
internet publishing that is new
um even a delay of an hour can be
consequential and
how well a piece does and that that's
that's different how do you describe
your audience like
um you know your your sub stock
subscribers like can you give kind of a
psychographic of them what you know who
are the people who are
reading you and paying you you know
gratefully out of their own Pockets you
know tons of dollars
yeah so my overall list which includes
the non-paying people I mean it's you
know it's around four hundred thousand
four hundred something thousand
um subscribers now and it's funny
originally
um I would say they were all
sort of Center Lefty people who knew me
from Rolling Stone but now this is a
very diverse audience that I have I have
hardcore Trump supporters I have lots
and lots of Independents who are like
disaffected hippies from the 60s who are
who are full of you know anger about
what's happened to the Democratic party
I have Libertarians I have people who
you know have never been a part of any
political movement it's really
interesting actually because of Rolling
Stone my audience was at was relatively
homogeneous yeah
um and that's not the case here how um
you you mentioned John wenner you know
who is kind of like a archetypal baby
boomer right and on late 60s Boomer who
among other things was you know one of
those guys who you know is like I'm in
favor of free speech no matter what
um one of your most recent pieces or you
know and like if you read the headlines
of your subsect of like one is where
have all the Liberals gone and other is
get off the first amendment's lawn uh
why Julian Assange must be freed the
elite war on free thought like something
has happened among people who broadly
call themselves liberals or progressives
where generationally up through probably
Gen X that was like
if not the most important issue like
free speech Uber all is then it was like
in the top three for younger people
maybe it doesn't seem to be as important
um do you agree with that and if so what
do you think has shifted that younger
people who are liberal and Progressive
may have the exact same political
commitments as you or like free speeches
is more of a problem than it is a
solution
I'm less in tune with what's going on
with people who are under 30 and how old
are you right now I'm 53 okay yeah
um
in my generation growing up I didn't
know anybody who wasn't
relatively a free speech absolutist
right like everybody I knew supported
Frank Zappa and D Snyder and the parent
against the parents music Resource
Center we were all in favor of NWA when
they you know every one of those
controversies you know to a Live Crew
yeah right yeah two Live Crew the even
the tape delay for Richard Pryor when he
went on Saturday Night Live right stuff
like that
um it was automatic it was a defining
issue for for a generation
um but there I think has been a Schism
you know within former liberals
uh it's it's clearer to me between
Boomers and gen xers like me you know I
mean you brought up John wenner there
was actually a moment at Rolling Stone
that I think was kind of significant
where
um in the primary season
uh for 2016 Jan did a big official
Rolling Stone editorial supporting
Hillary Clinton
and I was a little bit shocked by that
given the Magazine's history yeah and I
went to yawn personally and I said hey
would you mind if I wrote a descending
editorial
and I wrote One in favor of Bernie and
Jan's whole idea there was that the
world has changed since uh 1972. George
McGovern got beat
um we were wrong then we have to win now
and winning is the most important thing
and so forget about idealism and all
that stuff we cared about in the 60s and
70s and every and all that I mean I
thought this is supposed to be a
magazine for young people theoretically
right you know how is that gonna fly but
it did you know um and I I was a little
bit surprised by
um the reaction to both my editorial and
his that's fascinating that he as a
boomer is like yeah free speech oh you
know we can leave it
um because clearly younger Generations
seem less enamored of that and that's I
mean one of the things I think about
people you know squarely on the
Progressive left like you uh Tom Frank
Thomas Frank Glenn Greenwald Etc like
you evolved over the past few years have
articulate you know broken with identity
politics can you talk a little bit about
that and again in terms of policy
commitments I don't know that you're
that different but you know why don't
identity politics resonate with you
I don't believe a lot of the identity
politics that are being proffered by the
current version of the democratic party
are genuine and my first uh experience
with this where I really really thought
about this was when I was following
Bernie Sanders's campaign in
2016. and there was a moment in that
campaign where he first started to
really draw blood against Hillary right
um You might remember it was like in
February uh or late January of 2016 he
was hammering her on her ties to Goldman
Sachs and other Banks the New York Post
interestingly did this published this
big list of all of her speech
commitments and it was kind of amazing
and she wouldn't release the transcripts
right she wouldn't release the
transcripts but
um I mean even the schedule was amazing
she was doing three hundred thousand
dollars in the morning and then flying
to some place and doing 400 Grandad or
something yeah
circle of the Builder burgers or
whatever and they tried everything to
hit back and nothing worked until she
said
if we break up the banks tomorrow will
that end racism
and Bernie
was paralyzed by that yeah Bernie's an
old school he's a real comedy I mean I I
mean that like where it's class and
everything else is a distraction right
that you know you know you know
capitalists will use race in order to
keep the workers from realizing no
they're all on the same side well I I
would say I almost wish he was that
because you know Bernie also marched in
you know in for a civil rights movement
in the 60s and he was terrified of the
idea that he might be accused of race
racism it it mortified him and I think
it really slowed his campaign though
yeah I there was also that moment I
think it might have been in Seattle or
something where he was almost literally
pushed off the stage by a couple of
black activists who were like we need to
be talking about racial
concerns not whatever he was talking
about right not your class thing
whatever that is right and that and that
was when they started to
um sort of demonize the white working
class right which is a brilliant
strategic move also interestingly it was
the exact opposite of what the clintons
had done in the 90s you know the
Clinton's whole strategy was let's peel
off a little bit of that white working
class and we feel their pain we feel
their pain right and and that's you know
they just got over the Finish Line doing
that and now they
um so we can add to the sins of Hillary
Clinton that she also injected identity
politics I think so I think I think that
was a conscious thing that they did
um that they nothing was working for
them though I mean if you if you read
those books that one of the books about
the Hillary campaign there's a hilarious
chapter where they couldn't come up with
a slogan because they didn't even know
what they stood for like they were they
were toying with it's her turn you know
um and but this you know this whole idea
of identity politics being something
that they could Lord over somebody like
Bernie who was you know a legitimately
an oppositional movement and who was
drawing on this anger the same anger
that Trump was
um you know it worked it stopped him in
his tracks
um
the
um you know let's talk a little bit
about uh Julian Assange speaking Hillary
hated Julian Assange because she among
other things felt embarrassed by him you
know with the first big wikileaps dump
uh you know from Chelsea Manning uh you
know and on from that how do you how do
you make sense of journalists who
actually don't think that Julian Assange
should be like free to walk the planet
I mean it's stunning because these are
always the same people are like you know
the New York Times And The Washington
Post were so brave you know pushing back
against the Vietnam War publishing the
Pentagon papers
yeah and even publishing Assange at one
point right
um
I remember doing
um public service announcements with
other journalists uh I did one that was
um you know where everybody had to stand
up and say I am Bradley Manning it was
Bradley Manning back then uh but there
were a whole lot of people in the media
business and in that public service
announcement because everybody at that
time believed that of course this is
right you know we're we're exposing war
crimes what could be wrong with that
yeah and there was no question that the
the files were true like the information
was accurate nobody had any uh there's
never been an issue of factuality not
that I know of with with Wikileaks there
are some other ethical issues that I you
know I think are legitimate but with
factuality no
but the amazing thing about the reaction
that journalists have had since the
indictment is the total inability to to
see how this relates to the future of
Journalism I mean they're threatening
this guy with 175 years in prison for
doing basically the same thing that
every National Security journalist does
every day
um you know they're talking about
conspiracy to
um retain National Defense information
or obtaining National Defense
information well that happens all the
time I mean you this stuff doesn't even
have to be classified but we hear
classified things all the time when we
do reporting if that's going to be a
crime you can go to jail for 10 years
for and they're going to enforce that
how can you do reporting anymore and
everybody's all for it does that
disappear if Trump disappears I mean is
this all kind of an epic phenomenon of
trump is so uniquely awful and you know
and you have people Hunter Thompson
actually I guess said this more with
George W bush but that like you know
Nixon was bad Nixon you know the scumbag
of the universe was bad but George W
bush is really bad and I mean is it just
I mean I don't know is it like old
manism or something where it's like
Nixon was bad but Trump is the end of
the world and I don't think it's a
coincidence that the Obama
Administration didn't feel like it had
the Jews to indict
um Assange as much as they wanted to
right um but that after
Trump got elected ironically enough it
was Trump's own justice department that
did it but you know politically there
was a lot of support for that after this
story in 2016 about you know uh
Wikileaks possibly working with the
Russians again legally it doesn't matter
because the case is about an earlier
time period people don't think that way
anymore though
um so but I think you're right I think I
think absent Trump there this wouldn't
be happening but Will trump ever go away
then or is the threat of the next Trump
enough to kind of you know keep huffing
this type of
anti-first amendment or like where free
speech is free speech is negotiable now
going forward
I think one of the main things and we
found in the Twitter files was that if
it's not Trump it's something there's
always demon X that
um their warning audiences away from and
they always come up with a word that is
sort of a non-negotiable code for threat
so it's any vaxer right or domestic
violent extremist or insurrectionist or
anything you know something along those
lines Trump in that sense I think has
been an enormous Boon to the
intelligence Services they've been able
to say hey if you if you code AS
somebody who sides with Trump
um you know essentially they've created
um what I like to call it the sort of
one villain theory of the universe which
is if you're on Trump's side that means
you're on Putin's side which means
you're also on Assad side you're on
orban's side you're on the side of
domestic violence G somehow will end up
in that mix too right exactly it's all
kind of like an Edible Arrangement right
I mean you can just keep adding flavors
or something yeah and
rationally it's a crazy conspiracy
theory but
um they actually do
denialists and ban and and de-amplify
People based on ideas like that uh um
you know we're talking in Memphis where
Freedom Fest is you're speaking there
RFK Junior Robert F Kennedy Jr speaking
one of the things that's interesting
about RFK we've reason has talked to him
and we've critiqued him in all of this
but he self-consciously says he is
following a lot of Trump's Playbook like
he you know he I I saw an interview with
him where he said you know he
misunderstood Trump's appeal he was very
anti-trump but like now he's starting to
understand
why people looked at Trump seriously and
he wants to kind of grab some of that
what you know what is going on like why
do people like Trump and now RFK Jr what
what are they giving to people that
they're not getting out of traditional
candidates
I don't think it's that big of a mystery
I mean the very first time that I saw
Trump in person
I remember having the thought 20 minutes
into his speech this is gonna work I
mean I didn't know if he was going to
win
um but what he was doing was scoring you
could feel it in the audience and why
was that well America since 2008
especially had become incredibly
dysfunctional we had had a a massive
Financial collapse where the elite and
Wealthy class had been completely bailed
out when a lot of them should have gone
to jail
and everybody else sort of paid the bill
including millions of people who got
thrown out of their homes you know in
some cases justifiably but in some cases
not and you add that to the you know the
ongoing wars in the Middle East there
were lots of vets in Trump's crowds you
know who had gripes about all kinds of
things
um yeah and Trump picked up on anger at
institutional America that I think had a
legitimate basis if you've read Martin
Garry's book The Revolt of the public he
predicted this before Trump came on the
scene he said people are going to be
pissed about all these different things
and all it takes is somebody who's tuned
into that and my only concern about
Trump was that he was going to promise a
lot but not really deliver he was going
to be a fake reformer so if somebody
were to come along and be a you know a
real reformer if they were actually
going to try to do something about some
of these things that would probably have
a lot of appeal to the public do you
think RFK is that person
I think he's more honest than Donald
Trump I think
um you know the people that he
surrounded himself with are
real politicians I think they actually
care about a lot of these issues Trump
for me was a master at the appearance
side of the game right he was just so
good at visual politics and
um virality and all these things that
people didn't understand very well back
then but he wasn't a policy one he
wasn't staying up in that reading
position papers
um you know with Kennedy it's still
unknown I would say you know what house
in Syria is what what he's really up to
I think we have to get to know him a
little bit better
um with you know he's also coming onto
the scene post covid
um you know and Trump occupied a weird
space during coven right because it was
kind of like uh you know I'm not going
to tell you what to do I have experts
um but you know he was criticized for
not implementing a single policy which
in the end may have been better but then
he also you know he did Operation warp
speed which actually worked to get
vaccines out quickly they didn't come
quick before the election which he's
obviously still pissed about but he's
also kind of an anti-vaxxer how if 2008
was a moment where like okay you know
American institutions people are like
[__] it we're you know these These are
these are not working for us how much
worse is it post covet do you think I
think it's a lot worse post covet covid
has added to the dynamic that 2008 Iraq
yeah
um wmds all that stuff even the 2000
election where we couldn't really decide
yeah that too right you add that on top
of it but covet has a whole long list of
things that have added to Middle
America's grievances beginning with the
fact that it it increasingly looks like
they lied to us about the origins of the
disease
for some pretty weak reasons maybe
um you know they were trying to cover up
some research they were doing uh that's
thing one that's looking increasingly
likely at the very least they excluded
the possibility of that
um illegitimately and used I mean that
was where the government was telling
Twitter and Facebook at all like don't
run this stuff or they're squelch it
right exactly squelch that
um
then there was you know this whole idea
of tying anti-vaccine
um sentiment to anti-mandate sentiment
right right and they consciously blurred
the lines about that there were a lot of
people I did a story about Loudoun
County Virginia when you know the
Republicans won the gubernatorial
election there and there were people
there who were furious at the way they
had been portrayed in the media
um as racists or anti-vaxxers really
they wanted their kids to go back to
school because they had done their own
research online they found the kids
weren't really at risk and their kids
weren't learning anything and it was a
burden on them personally right so
there's a million things like this that
have added to ordinary people's
dissatisfaction and again with covet
there's the additional
complicating factor of kids being
involved like once you know peop people
feel strongly but once once there's
something about their kids and once it
be and it became clear pretty early on
that kids were not affected and yet they
were the ones who were whose lives were
most clearly upended by this right by
lockdowns one where are you on like
vaccines are you an anti-covet vaxxer
are you anti-mandate are you Pro mandate
pro-vaccine or I'm anti-mandit for sure
you know
um and you know my wife's a doctor I'm
pretty okay reliably convinced that
vaccines have been a good thing overall
in in the world
um I yeah you know I I I'm not a
scientist this is one of the reasons why
I stayed away from the story is because
this is not my ex area of expertise but
um I I do think lockdowns have been bad
uh I do think the the Press
lied about the threat to kids
and I don't understand why they had to
do that
um I'm not I'm not so sure about the
efficacy of vaccinating children at all
you know this recent Missouri V Biden
case involved some doctors who just said
some very logical things like if there's
any risk at all with this vaccine even
if it's infinitesimal it's probably more
than the risk of sending your kid to
school
because you know this thing doesn't
really hurt kids and they've tossed them
off Twitter for that or they tossed them
on Facebook for that that's crazy you
know and I think people see that as
crazy the uh you know the other big
story that parallel coveted in the
lockdowns obviously was George Floyd and
kind of racial Reckoning and whatnot you
had it was a 2019 when you were at the
Eric Garner book uh or earlier 18 I
think yeah yeah I mean which is a you
know before the lockdown and things like
that but how you know obviously you know
the George Floyd's story was huge and it
was you know again it probably wouldn't
have been as big if we weren't in
lockdown and whatnot but go back to Eric
Garner who was arrested for selling
loose cigarettes in Staten Island and
then died while the police were
arresting him
um where where do you think we are in
terms of kind of Criminal Justice Reform
as well as race relations
um is are we better than 2019 or you
know or Eric Garner time or is it worse
or is it just kind of like an open wound
that we never quite can close or heal I
don't know I mean I haven't spent a lot
of time in the last couple of years
looking at local policing I did for many
years spent a lot of time in the courts
and you know doing Street reporting the
George Floyd summer was very frustrating
for me personally because the big lesson
that I came away from was from the
George Floyd story was that broken
windows policing had massively increased
the number of contacts between the
ordinary Citizen and police which in
turn resulted in a lot of these
situations going wrong and people dying
and the one thing that's fixable in this
whole milia
um is we can change that we can change
statistics-based policing we don't have
to order people to stop you know 20
people a month or whatever it is and it
never came up I mean it was it was like
it was purposely excluded from the floor
it didn't seem to be serving anybody's
interests right right everybody
abstracted immediately to your your
racist you're not racist or something
right because it wasn't it it didn't
have a tie to
America's racist past uh you know the
inherent uh tendency towards white
supremacy now there are obviously
enormous racial overtones to police
brutality and I detailed a lot of them
in you know my book
but it's only part of the picture I mean
it's this is just the same thing as like
Trump coverage uh people picked one
thing and that became the in the entire
lens through which they looked at that
story and they ignored all these other
you know Shades of Gray and complexities
um and made I think they left audiences
less informed than they were before as a
result
um part I got uh to kind of wrap up one
of the things I find most interesting
about your your kind of post
mainstream media output and you've
started a podcast or you where you
talked with Walter Kern the novelist and
a lot of what you're doing is you're
talking about stuff like uh you know
Mark Twain's the man that corrupted
Hadley Berg or you know classic stories
American stories Etc what's the goal
there and what has the response been
part of it is just because Walter Kern
and I
um both like talking about books we
don't get to do it very much we've
decided to experiment what would happen
if we did that and
um what we found is people are so tired
of the Relentless sort of binary nature
of media these days
TMX versus Team y team blue versus red
and it's divisive it's anti-intellectual
you don't get to talk about anything
interesting in these shows it's always
an argument and it's a dumb argument
that just never ends and I mean this was
part of I mean this is the basis of hate
Inc your book about what's the subtitle
why today's media make us hate each
other yeah exactly exactly and I think
it's it's a kind of a bad product unless
you're
um unless you have some kind of amazing
breaking news that's about to come out
why would you watch it I mean it just
makes you depressed what we found is
when we talked about these stories we're
getting into all these
um issues and also we're also finding
that a lot of these old stories that
um you know maybe dust covered in
people's imaginations they're amazingly
relevant today you know the EM Foresters
of the machine stops
um has a lot of relevance to can you do
a quick summary what what's the plot of
that yeah the plot of that the Ian
Forster
um imagined a world where people no
longer had to do anything they lived
underground
um machines basically did everything for
them they were told that if they went
outside they would die immediately there
were legends about that so uh but one
day the machine starts to malfunction
because the people who were are taking
care of the machine they've started to
die off and so the thing has started to
malfunction and people slowly realized
that they've been had it's actually safe
to go outside and a lot of the Legends
they've been
um told to keep them afraid and keep
them indoors and keep them
from acting out on their own are fake
and that's very true of Internet culture
I think we you know we're a lot of us
are
captured by our neuroses now right we
don't have as much face-to-face contact
with people and
um it's it's very relevant today you
know and and it was so much fun talking
about that and we got a great response
from people who you know who are saying
um there's a whole world of thought out
there that they're telling us doesn't
exist anymore but it it is out there you
know and people are learning to enjoy it
again I think we're going to leave it
there math taibi thanks for talking to
reason great thanks so much
foreign
[Music]